this video was made possible by morning
brew start your day catching up on
what's happening in business finance and
tech by signing up for their free daily
newsletter at the link in the
description
in our lifetimes the dominant story of
economic explosion has been that of
china
previously it was a poor vast peripheral
country in mere decades though its
growth has pulled it to center stage and
the country now plays a serious role in
world affairs with the core of that
transformation now behind us however
many have asked the question
who's next which corner of the world is
set for a similar dramatic rise in the
coming years plenty of candidates come
up but one of the most frequently
floated names is africa it's a continent
with a huge population but a generally
lower level of economic development it's
a region that often in many ways falls
behind but that means the only direction
to go is up so is the african continent
poised to become the next china the next
darling of the world economy
africa is a sprawling continent three
times the size of europe composed of 54
countries 1.4 billion people and
countless religions languages ethnic
groups and cultures many appropriately
criticize media when they overzealously
refer to the continent as one
generalizing what's happening in part of
the continent to its entirety but there
is logic and precedent for examining
africa as a cohesive unit from an
economic lens at least for the purposes
of simplicity economists and journalists
often group related countries together
into business regions for example often
economists will look at the european
economy as a whole since france's
economy for example is deeply interwoven
with germany's so their fates are
essentially tied meanwhile they'll often
look at china by itself since it's large
enough to be analogous to europe but
also unique and isolated enough
economically that grouping it with japan
for example would not be appropriate
japan can prosper when china does not
and vice versa that's why china is worth
examining on its own while africa is
examined as a whole
the countries that compose the continent
are economically interlinked and add up
to a population comparable to china's
therefore in this context one could
expect that the development potential of
africa
could be roughly akin to that of china
but we can quantify this the african
continent's current gross domestic
product is 2.69 trillion dollars chinese
gdp in 2006 was inflation-adjusted 2.89
trillion dollars meaning the african
economy today is roughly analogous to
that of 2006 china this is backed up by
the fact that africa's gdp per capita is
currently thousand thirty dollars while
2006 china's was two thousand one
hundred dollars africa's urbanization
rate is roughly equal to china's in 2008
while their foreign direct investment
inflows are about the same as china's in
1992. all around these four important
economic development indicators suggest
that africa stands roughly 20 years
behind today's china
now it would be staggering if this were
the case if in a mere two decades the
african economy would be as relevant as
china's today
of course some would have said the same
about china decades ago but economic
indicators are often counter-intuitively
not the most helpful in determining
economic growth prospects
china did not grow off of natural
resources so too africa is not likely to
grow off of natural resources
both have extensive resources but
economists have observed a phenomenon
globally that they refer to as the
resource curse essentially an abundance
of natural resources does not regularly
translate well into sustainable economic
growth the reasons behind this are hotly
contested and quite complex but one of
the simpler contributing factors is the
tendency of resource-based economies to
concentrate wealth to a select few while
a diamond mine owner might grow rich the
workers in the mine aren't learning any
skills that they can use to innovate
start their own business and grow the
economy they just aren't getting
educated and there's no direct incentive
on a national level to improve formal
education since the money that's being
made is through jobs that do not require
a high level of education in the case of
china manufacturing which was a major
driving force behind its development
gave many of the skills needed to start
their own businesses and there is now a
significant homegrown tech sector in
china that's helping to carry its
economy beyond manufacturing so if
africa is going to have a china-style
economic explosion it's going to be
because of human capital rather than
natural resources
however that's where the story gets less
optimistic
one relevant demographic indicator is
the dependency ratio that's a number
calculated by dividing the population 14
and under or 65 and over by the
population between those ages while it's
not perfect it's a rough index of how
many people each working person in an
economy has to support either directly
or through welfare systems now in
general lower dependency ratios are
better for an economy having less people
to support and a greater percent of
people working is financially beneficial
and correspondently most developed
economies have low dependency ratios the
us for example has a dependency ratio of
54 percent indicating that for every 10
working age people there are 5.4
dependents africa's meanwhile is 79
far higher largely due to the large
youth population in many of the
continent's countries that puts this
metric closest to china's in 1974 before
their dependency ratio plummeted in step
with falling birth rates as the country
started to encourage then mandate one
child per couple so this demographic
indicator is relative to china's far
behind chronologically compared to the
earlier economic indicators but as
important as the current state of the
dependency ratio is to an economy a
stronger predictor of the future is the
trend is the ratio rising falling or
staying the same the answer for africa
is easy continent-wide the average in
1990 was 93
compared to today's 79 percent their
dependency ratio is falling but this is
like the 2d view of this demographic
shift what's even more useful is the 3d
view the population pyramid
these graphs are simple each row
represents a five-year age bracket with
the left side indicating the size of the
male population in that bracket and the
right side the female population
africa's pyramid indicates that the
continent has a disproportionately young
population which is common for less
developed regions meanwhile europe's
population pyramid like those of many
more developed regions indicates that
its population is disproportionately
middle-aged as it ages and birth rates
decline now china's pyramid is
undoubtedly affected by the impact of
its one child policy but looking at its
progression since 1950 it demonstrates a
powerful phenomenon through the 50s and
60s birth rates are higher meaning a
large youth population arises then
starting in the 70s birth rates decline
but the large youth population is still
alive and moves into working age this
population bubble moves up the pyramid
creating a situation where there is a
huge working age population and very few
youth or seniors that this population
has to support by 2010 this pushed
china's dependency ratio down to just 36
percent almost unprecedentedly low for a
large economy in fact today the only
countries with a lower dependency ratio
are small nations like qatar the uae or
singapore which have high immigrant
labor populations that grow up and
retire in their home countries thereby
skewing the statistics now china's
dependency ratio has since creeped up to
42 percent as this bulging population
from the 50s and 60s has started to move
into retirement age becoming dependents
once again but the time period with the
lowest dependency ratio corresponds well
with the period in which the country
experienced the most dramatic economic
growth one study found that china can
attribute 9.2 percent of its economic
growth between 1960 and 2000 to this
bulge in the working age population
that's a small percent in isolation but
in the context of the complexities of
national development
massive at the simplest level people and
the government could invest money into
growth rather than social support for
the young and old which helped
accelerate development the economic
boost that ensues from this short-term
population bulge has a name it's called
the demographic dividend estimates
indicate a demographic dividend is
coming for africa as its birth rates
decline but potentially one less
pronounced than china's current
population projections would put
africa's 2050 dependency ratio at 60.7
percent certainly a significant
improvement from today's 79
but a far cry from china's 36
low points in fact that dependency ratio
is higher than today's world average
which sits at 54.5 percent the future is
not however set in stone now the
demographic dividend typically isn't as
some might speculate a byproduct of
development itself it's well established
that birth rates fall in step with
development but recent research suggests
that the strongest trigger for a
demographic dividend is in fact
education women have fewer children when
they are better educated currently
africa's average secondary school
enrollment by women as a proportion of
total female population of secondary
school age is 48.56
china first attained that level in 1977
before it briefly dipped as a result of
the abandonment of cultural revolution
era education policies now of course
improved education often comes with
development meaning the three factors
work in cycle better education leads to
a lower dependency ratio which leads to
faster development which leads to better
education and so on and so forth beyond
the dividend africa's current
demographic status relative to china's
can be further corroborated for example
the continent's average fertility rate
is closest to china's in 1974 its life
expectancy parallels china's in 1976
infant fatality rate 1981 and literacy
rate 1982. looking at this timeline with
the addition of the earlier economic
indicators two defined clusters appear
the demographic indicators and the
economic indicators economically africa
is in the 2000s demographically it's in
the 70s
of course there's a big wide world of
chance and circumstance out there that
can get in the way and this is a narrow
way of analyzing economic prospects in
the first place but this narrow method
does present two primary conclusions
first africa is primed for development
in all quantifiable ways the continent
is in a similar or better position than
when china began its period of explosive
growth in the 70s and 80s this isn't to
say the growth will inevitably happen
but it is to say that there's nothing in
the indexes that suggests that the
continent on average isn't ready or
capable of starting that growth in fact
there's everything to suggest that
africa is in the exact right situation
for a similar manner of growth to start
however secondly the gap between
economic and demographic indicators
should raise red flags it suggests that
what's holding growth back if anything
is not the economic situation of africa
it's the state of the population the
indexes are in aggregate headed in the
right direction but if african countries
want to reap the explosive growth
benefits of a demographic dividend they
have to concentrate on measures to
improve family planning keep more young
girls in school and bring more women
into the workforce as much as these
measures might seem like ones done
because it's the right thing to do
because improving gender equity is a
positive for a country's international
image the demographic dividend proves
that they cause tangible significant
economic effects downstream going back
to this cycle better education causing
lower dependency ratios causing faster
development what is the easiest phase in
the cycle to effect a country can't just
speed up development by itself that's
the end goal but not a factor that a
country can directly manipulate
dependency ratios are easier for a
country to affect but measures like
china's one child policy are viewed as
draconian and often difficult to
implement voluntary family planning
programs have seen success in certain
countries but are undoubtedly complex
the easiest phase in this cycle to
manipulate is education because by its
very nature it's something that the
country's government manages
the demographic dividend isn't some
silver bullet for explosive development
rather it's one small yet powerful
example of the merits of investing in
people it's an example backing up the
suggestion that africa's economies
should not be focusing all their
attention on juicing foreign direct
investment inflows by courting
superpowers for development projects for
example
that's important but so is just getting
kids in school getting households hooked
up to electricity getting people to
participate in elections improving
people's quality of life matters far
beyond just quality of life so
is africa the next china
well
probably not despite the parallels china
is made up of one country
africa 54.
china got things right once africa is
unlikely to get things right 54 times
the data suggests that in aggregate the
conditions are ripe for development but
there's still work to do
some countries will put in that work and
trigger a gold rush while others will
not the others will eventually realize
their fault and start to catch up but
this means that the fate of the
continent will likely become less and
less intertwined by centuries end
certain african economies will almost
certainly be talked about the way china
is discussed today but the disconnected
nature of the development process will
likely mean that the global impact of
this transformation will be less intense
that being said the conditions are there
and the time is right by recognizing
their shortcomings and focusing on human
development africa might not be the next
china but african countries
just might be
if you've sat through all that talk of
indexes and demographics and development
you clearly enjoy learning about how the
world works
i obviously do too and one way i do that
is to start my day not by browsing
twitter or tick tock but by reading
through morning brews free daily
newsletter it always arrives in my inbox
before i wake up and catches me up to
speed on the most relevant stories in
business finance and tech in a witty
informative style that's far more
readable than traditional news for
example this morning i was reading about
the democratic party's proposed
billionaires tax why college enrollment
is falling in the u.s and how 3d printed
houses could be a solution to the
construction industry's labor shortage
following the news consistently is just
about the best way to become better
informed and morning brew just makes it
so easy especially considering their
newsletter is free seriously it's not a
free trial not a discount just a free
newsletter so give morning brew a shot
by clicking the button on screen or
heading to the link in the description
and you'll be helping support wendover
while you're at it